Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a Comedy short film called “Alternative
Math.” Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set in a “post-fact”
American society where everything you say
has to align with everyone else’s opinion.
In an elementary school, math teacher Mrs. Wells
invites a student, Danny, to her class. Danny has
failed his recent math test terribly and is very
mad about it. However, he isn’t mad that he didn’t
do well on the test, instead, he is bothered by
the teacher who gave him bad grades and said all
of his answers were wrong. Danny shows Mrs. Wells
his answer sheet full of red markings and a big
F on the top. The teacher calmly takes a look at
his paper and explains that his answers are wrong.
Seeing that the kid has written two plus two
is equal to twenty-two, it is clear that he is
having some trouble with addition. Being the
good teacher that she is, Mrs. Wells asks the
boy to not be upset because it is normal for
kids his age to be confused by numbers. She
explains that he is here to learn and that making
mistakes is a part of the learning experience.
But by the look on Danny’s face, her kind words
went over his head. He expresses his confusion
with a sassy “nuh-uh” to his teacher’s face.
Mrs. Wells remains composed and asks him to look
at the questions again. She points out his obvious
mistake but Danny seems to be uninterested. Mrs.
Wells further explains that two plus two doesn’t
equal twenty-two because addition doesn’t mean
you can just put the numbers next to each other,
you have to add them. As she explains how he can
add the numbers, the kid scoffs and says that her
method is stupid. The woman manages to suppress
her frustration and tries giving him a practical
example. She brings out two markers in each of
her hands and puts them together asking the kid
how many markers she has in total. With all the
sass he can gather, Danny replies that the answer
is twenty-two. Finally starting to get irritated,
Mrs. Wells tells him he is wrong and the obvious
answer is four. The spoiled kid pushes the box
of markers off the desk and storms out of the
classroom in anger. Mrs. Wells is left speechless
by the kid’s behavior but she doesn’t think much
of it. Until the very next day when his parents
come to her classroom with a complaint.
At first, they introduce themselves politely
and take a seat at Mrs. Wells’s request.
Before the parents can voice their concerns,
the teacher assures them that there is nothing
to worry about. She further adds that it is
completely normal for kids like Danny to get
frustrated when they are struggling with a
subject, especially a subject like math where they
can hardly use their creativity. Danny’s mother
doesn’t seem to be grateful for Mrs. Wells’s kind
words. She ignores everything the teacher says and
asks why Danny is getting some answers wrong in
her “so-called” test. Mrs. Wells is taken aback by
the rudeness but doesn’t show it in her face. She
composes herself and starts explaining what kind
of questions were on the test. After she states
that Danny’s answer to the question; what is two
plus two was twenty-two, the room goes silent.
One might think the parents realized that it was
their son’s mistake but to Mrs. Wells’s surprise,
they ask her to go on, waiting for her to prove
her point. It is clear that the couple doesn’t
understand that the kid’s answer is wrong.
The teacher bluntly says that twenty-two is not
the right answer. The mother, in utter disbelief,
asks Mrs. Wells who says that the answer is wrong.
Mrs. Wells replies that is how math works. The
couple misses the whole point and accuses Mrs.
Wells of calling their son stupid. The teacher
explains that it was not her intention and that
she is simply trying to correct his mistake.
Things get heated when the dad starts to yell. He
asks Mrs. Wells who she is to declare his son’s
answer is wrong and hers is right. Mrs. Wells is
in complete shock at the stupidity of the couple.
She tries to reason with them stating that the
answers are factual and they would never change.
The mother acts like she understands Mrs.
Wells’s words but then accuses her of being
a Nazi and forcing absolute answers
on her child. Confused by everything,
the teacher bluntly asks the two if they know
what two plus two equals to. Instead of an answer,
Mrs. Wells gets insults thrown at her. The father
calls her a smart ass tramp then mocks her accent.
Their politeness from a while ago vanishes in
thin air as they get more and more aggressive.
Still being respectful, Mrs. Wells tells them
that she can no longer continue the conversation
and shows them the way out. Danny’s mother claims
that they are going to complain to the principal
while his father shouts his son is a free
thinker for saying the answer is twenty-two.
Before leaving, the mother threatens to get
her kicked out of the job and calls her a
bitch. Having had enough of the two, Mrs. Wells
sarcastically shames them for not knowing what two
plus two is. The scene abruptly ends as the mother
slaps Mrs. Wells on her face. The following day,
the principal comes to Mrs. Wells’s class to
discuss the matter. He immediately gets to the
point and asks her what the issue was with Danny’s
parents. Mrs. Wells announces that it got a little
crazy because the parents weren’t cooperating.
She inquires how the management is handling the
situation only to find out that they want her to
apologize to the parents. This makes her even mad
because the mother was the one who hit her. The
principal has a problem with Mrs. Wells telling
the kids that their answer is wrong. A confused
Mrs. Wells says that it is her job as a teacher
to tell them when they make mistakes. However,
the principal doesn’t share the same view.
He claims that the teachers should not ram
their biased views down the students’ throats
because the students have their own opinions.
In the new and modernized world, everything has
to be politically correct. It is wrong to declare
a kid’s answer incorrect because of your opinion.
Mrs. Wells is left stunned, she claims that
math cannot be biased because it is factual.
The principal starts getting annoyed and says
that Mrs. Wells’s attitude is making the situation
worse. He scornfully tells her that she is giving
the children zero respect which is against their
school’s policies. That day, a crowd of parents
assembles in front of the school and protests
against the teachers’ absolute behavior. Mrs.
Wells is shoved by the crowd who asks her to stop
undermining their kids’ confidence. Some of them
even demand her to apologize to the parents she
offended by claiming that two plus two is four.
Things get worse when they accuse her of hating
children in general. Sensing the situation getting
more serious, the school’s superintendent and
his council hold a meeting with Mrs. Wells.
She nervously asks the board of men to wait for
a week or two for the situation to blow over. But
the superintendent claims they cannot wait because
the parents are suing the school for emotional
distress to a minor. Mrs. Wells exclaims that she
only said two plus two is four, which shouldn’t
have caused this much trouble. The board members
scoff at the comment and reply that she should
admit the possibility of multiple correct answers
to the same question. Mrs. Wells is in absolute
disbelief. She knows that she is right but the
world seems to have changed to a weird place
where every answer must be true and every fact
is debatable. The principal accuses her of
portraying everyone who disagrees with her
as stupids. When Mrs. Wells stays put in her
opinion, the board members suspend her and
ask her to reconsider her extremist views if she
ever wants to get back to her job. The next day,
Mrs. Wells packs up all her belongings
from the school and returns home.
At night, she watches the TV and finds out that
the scandal has made the national television.
Many political leaders are debating if two
plus two equals twenty-two or four. The media
exaggerates the news and calls Mrs. Wells an
activist who was caught abusing a kid’s first
amendment rights. She is being called a liberal
elitist for saying that four is the definite
answer to the simple question. Some even belittle
Mrs. Wells for not keeping the students in her
class for more than a year, to which Mrs.
Wells angrily says it’s called graduating.
While she is watching the news, annoyed at the
stupidity of the reporters, she gets a call from
the school. The principal informs her that she has
officially been fired. He also asks her to come by
the school the next day and requests her to stop
radicalizing the students. The following day, Mrs.
Wells goes to the school for the last time.
As she walks through the entrance,
she is greeted by a group of reporters patiently
waiting for her. The school has invited them to
prove they do not support Mrs. Wells’s extremist
view and to make it clear she is no longer
their employee. Before officially signing the
papers and ending her contract with the school,
the principal says he will pay her the monthly
salary for the last two terms. The salary rounds
up to two thousand dollars for the last month and
two thousand for this one. The principal says that
is four thousand dollars in total but at last,
Mrs. Wells claps back and claims it is actually
twenty-two thousand dollars. The movie ends as the
principal awkwardly looks towards the reporters
and back at a smiling Mrs. Wells.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.